Look, I don't know how much
of this you wanna hear.
I wasn't happy
with who I was.
Figured anyone
who was close to me
would see that too.
Sooner or later.
So I went looking
for something.
Something that'd make me...
I don't know,
worthy.
The whole time just...
making shit worse and...
hurting more people.
Thank you.
There is no fixing it.
That's what I finally
figured out.
Look, I'm sorry.
I know this is a lot
to hit you with.
It's why we go
to the meetings, man.
getting older
doesn't mean you get wiser.
I've got two marriages,
daughter won't talk to me,
some grandkids
I've never met,
believe me when I tell you
man, this shit isn't easy.
I've been an op four year
and I'm still trying to make
things right.
Yeah.
I know one thing,
70 grand never hurts.
No, it does not.
You drive here?
Yeah.
Drugs in the back.
Well, I'm gonna make a call.
It's cool if you follow me.
Meet my other guy.
Sounds good, buddy.
Thanks.
If she comes by
I'd get the check.
Doug is making the call.
Setting a meet.
Stand by in the parking lot.